i chose to ditch apple's large max model
phones and for the first time since i
can remember go with the smaller 6.1
inch model the smaller iphone 13 pro has
the same exact camera system and the
whole 1080p prores really pushed me over
that edge and finally got me to spend
extra on more storage but four months
later i am not shooting prores at all so
if you're somebody that is wondering
about that and thinking about spending
extra money on storage for that i
wouldn't do it thankfully battery life
actually got quite a bit better after
about a month or so and i can now get
through a full day and still have about
10 to 15 battery left when i go to plug
it in and charge it at night well i have
to say that i love this smaller phone
the 6.1 inch size is perfect in the hand
i will say that for gaming that is the
one area where i do sometimes wish that
i had the larger display so overall
after finally ditching the massive max
phone and going with a smaller model i'm
really happy that i did that and i have
no regrets